okay so for the last month I've been
smack dab in the middle of this ninja's
of the jammas controversy that you might
have heard about I spoken with players
like flarin exist Freiburg and Dragan
and they've told me things from not
being paid prize money tax is not being
filed and just general shady behavior
but here's the thing last week I spoke
with nip management for two hours on the
record and according to them there's a
logical explanation for all of this
[Music]
okay so that two-hour interview that was
with Hashem Shaheen ni peas current CEO
but who is Hisham well he's the guy
that's been catching a lot of flak this
past month over allegations that the
players have been flying around the
frustrating part of my end has been to
sit on the sidelines and observe how
this is gone in particular given that we
in 2016 with previous management when we
had the whole cleanup during that phase
signed NDA with previous management so
when you're sitting there and all of
this are going on and you have all these
things you want to say your hands are
tied because you want to respect those
agreements you put in place the
community conversation in that sense is
is actually fair I also talked with nip
co-founder email Christensen you guys
probably know him as Heaton the
legendary CS 1.6 player he basically
denies all of the allegations that we're
about to get into so just keep that in
mind as we move through this story well
first of all my first expression was to
save an IP that's my legacy and that's
everything I did if I did something
wrong during this I did probably a lot
of things wrong during this but my only
intention was to save an IP so the
company could live on the name could
live on that the players could keep
getting a salary to play that was my
only intention ever ever ever there have
been some pretty wild allegations when
it comes to contracts things like
girlfriend applications $20,000 fines
and players being benched for who
[ __ ] knows how long I wouldn't be
surprised if it's true from the time
that they were running the company I can
say though that there is no rule that
you can't have a girlfriend at an IP
today but what I know the team has done
at occasions is if they're playing a
major they don't want girlfriends
staying with the players at the hotels
right when I reviewed the old old
contracts because I have access to them
and when I came in we were still on the
old contract templates which I was like
ok this is the last time we sign on this
contract they were done at a time where
eSports was not the level that is today
was still very unprofessional
the biggest flaw in those contracts when
I reviewed them and looked at him is
that they're not consistent like if you
point out specific clause you mentioning
the 20k fine clause as an example let's
say that you
a player you're signed on the on a
salary in proportion to your salary that
might be a very high amount the way we
do today is that you have four minor
breaches right and those are very small
amounts there's more like a little slap
on the hands and that is how it should
be done I also talked with heatin about
these contract clauses and he denies
ever being involved in the process of or
signing those player contracts I was
never in charge how many contracts never
did in myself because I'm a k-mer and I
play games and I was a public figure out
but behind the curtains I didn't do
anything really okay so we got the
contracts out of the way
now this whole ninjas in pajamas [ __ ]
show actually began with an emergency
meeting the players were called to in
December of 2013
okay so in this weird ass meeting the
players were not only told that then CEO
Nicolas Fisher had fled to Thailand with
the team's prize money none of that
prize money had been taxed yet but
according to Freiburg that emergency
meeting was even crazier than we
initially thought because apparently the
players were told that if they didn't
re-sign right then and there the
investors that were brought in to save
the company would leave I think Robin
was a bit too nice they literally told
us that we will get a big tax tip and
they they almost tried to force us into
signing the contract while in the house
and saying that if you leave without
signing the contract they often first
come like they offered us to stand and
immerse it they kind of like Curtis in
this position we're like we were shocked
and like wow like we're if they're all
our money gone we will get a tax step
and they literally said yeah but if you
don't leave today your offer or our
offer is gone and like your left eye in
the dirt basically when we asked Heat
about this he just said it never
happened I mean this is six seven years
ago but I mean my purpose for everything
was obviously to save the guy's ass as
for the situation that Nicolas has put
them in and obviously when I finally
found somebody who could cover it up for
them it's a I would have to say it's
pretty nice because he really put but
all both the players and and me in a
really tough situation now here's where
Hashim comes into the picture he was the
new money guy that was supposed to save
an IP
heading into 2014 in 2013 I did a lot
with ml and one day in 2014 I get a
phone call from Robert saying that hey
sham I need to talk to you about
something serious and IP is in trouble
the old CEO of an IP has essentially
taken all the money from the company and
fled to Thailand and we need to help mo
that is how an IP really came up
obviously I've been an IP fan my whole
life but it wasn't something I was
actively pursuing at the time it was
just really cool even though it was a
very unfortunate situation and I felt
really bad for mo and felt bad for the
players it was like okay it's an
opportunity to get involved and
hopefully give them the right financing
and the right capitalization and
resources and maybe help and contribute
for them to not get into the situation
they had in 2014 again now Hisham comes
in gets told about the alleged stolen
prize money and doesn't question it
because to him that's not what's
important what's important is trying to
fix this situation Robert and I had been
working together and that working
relationship was great right so I kind
of over those years have built up trust
right I was also very young at age I saw
him as the more experienced guy that
kind of drove what we did with the
gunner business forward so when he came
to me and said this is how it is I
didn't really question it right
I just thought thought really oh [ __ ]
that is really bad and Hashem says that
the idea he would ever pull his
investment if things weren't moving fast
enough is ridiculous now Hashem did
state that he and ni P promised to pay
the tax fees if the players got in
trouble while also working with an
auditing firm to sort out the financial
mess that the company was in okay guys
we will do a guarantee for you if this
is going to happen in 2014 15 and 16
where they actually come after you for
that we are going to guarantee that
amount for you guys so you can focus on
competing and doing your best right so
it was more about giving them this
security from our end paid and hired one
of Sweden's largest Auditor firms which
is called mizar's to deal on behalf of
all the players with the sweet
tax authorities in the private cases as
it was difficult for players to handle
their private income taxes right the old
management and old company hadn't
educated them in the process of what it
entails to have your private income
declaration you might have had done all
sorts of very various things as a player
and get income paid directly to you
privately which they hadn't filed in
their private income taxes because
people hadn't simply educated them on
how to do that
right he also said that ni P paying the
taxes was not supposed to be looked at
as a pressuring tactic but more as a
goodwill gesture in an incentive to stay
with the organization that was never
used as like a pressuring method the
same contract for me it was more it was
more guests sure look at him more as a
signing incentive right guys I had
nothing to do with Stockholm eSports
production but I want you to come over
and continue an IP with us and I don't
want you to think or worry about the tax
situation you guys should be out there
at events on the server's practicing and
focusing on your game and know that if
something happens that's taken care of
when I talked to Heaton about the
financial issues the company was having
he denied anything to do with the
paperwork and pointed to Pfizer as the
one responsible i I really didn't I I
had the full-time job working at
SteelSeries while Nicholas ran the
company I never worked
I was only posing on pictures but behind
the curtains Nicholas was doing
everything ok so we're done with the
taxes everybody still with me ok so all
of this [ __ ] happened prior to him
becoming ni P's official CEO in 2016 but
according to flarin while he might not
have officially been CEO hisham was
definitely involved prior to 2016
now Hashim has been adamant that this
isn't the case and told me as much in
our interview the community perspective
perception is that I was much more
involved than I was but as an investor
it was it was projects right that we we
had going on I would in the initial
phase be very involved in ok let's set
up the company the legal documents you
guys have a bank account like banal
things like this I would be consulted
when we did big projects so president
when we established extra-fine gaming
that is a very big decision for a come
of course I was involved in that I also
had frequent calls with management but
those would happen on on more of a
weekly or monthly basis right so was not
this day-to-day management down into the
details dealing with players accounting
salaries prize money's there going to
events the tournaments it wasn't this
level of management I also asked him
about having majority voting control of
the board and he chalked it up to
protecting his investment if something
would come along in the future when went
to three years you always had the
opportunity to make sure your money was
safe in Sweden in order to run a company
solely on herself
you need majority voting and that is
sixty six point sixty seven percent to
be specific but when you have a sixty
percent voting power you can always say
no so it was in the sense minority
ownership
a man was majority owner of the company
and the voting power in the technical
aspect gave me the opportunity to just
stop things I wasn't comfortable with
now when I talked with fiber Bergen
exist they told me that the issues with
Hedon and nip management extended well
into 2015 and it got to the point where
Fryeburg says there was an
us-versus-them mentality for example we
we've told them we never wanted a skin
gambling site because there was a lot of
skin gambling happening in csgo back
then where a lot of like especially
young people it wasn't really restricted
it was people under 18 was gambling
throwing away money we were big role
models for a lot of people in Sweden and
globally I guess as well they played see
us and we didn't really want anything to
do with that so we told them don't get
any skin sponsor we were at the
tournament in Montreal in the estoppel
you see and I remember that we got a
call from Heath on in Paris telling us
that they have got enough skilled
sponsor now and we really just went
against that we've said like we told you
guys we don't want anything to do with
it we don't wanna like put our names on
this that should go out to people who
are underage and still could gamble but
they told us like the contracts are
already signed you can't do anything
about it exists echo that not only did
they want nothing to do with this
sponsorship they didn't even see any of
the money after the fact we didn't have
that much of salary done and we kind of
thought okay we just got this huge
sponsor sugar is like
our salaries well not just management
but they basically told us just read
your contract you have two more years so
for whatever it was at the time and then
we don't wanna discuss anything like
yeah we're going to treat it so good I
think
and when Freiburg was trying to leave an
IP the issues got worse you had a lot of
issues getting for example prize money
and everything like that they were
trying to find loopholes in the contract
because even those contracts were not
perfect either
so they kind of like screwed us over
according to Freiburg there was a clause
in their contract that stated they had
the stream for up to 10 hours every
month but when we talked to him and
exist they said some months their travel
schedule and practice schedule was so
intense they couldn't meet that
stipulation we were not able to do that
we were travelling so much and when we
came home after tournament we were
practicing and everything like that but
I was dreaming a little bit but I
probably didn't reach the 10 hours point
and after leaving an IP Hisham then said
oh we will pay you all the price money
and everything but according to Freiburg
when he went to his home to ask about
the prize money he was owed from
starladder kiev he was met with a
different story he some came to me like
a few months later saying we will not be
able to pay the prize money unless you
stream in the hours that you have missed
and apparently it was a lot of hours and
he told me that they would find me with
I think was 25k dollars which was the
same amount of money that they owed me
Courtley I still owe me today that I
haven't streamed in then I contacted the
other guys I was asking him like during
this period like have you guys gotten
pay from this tournament it's been a
really long time now like the money
surely must have been there and they
said yeah we got paid a few months ago
with this and I asked all four of them
and all four it was only me who didn't
get my prize money and that was because
I was the only guy who wasn't on a team
anymore
now when I asked him about Fryeburg
situation Hashem told me that Fryeburg
owed ni P more money in lost streaming
time then ni P actually owed him in
prize money the players when we had a
dialogue with them over the years there
was a month or two where they weren't
required to stream it was either a major
qualifier or something but they always
neglected doing it and in Fryeburg skate
when I received the twitch statistics
you're talking
fourteen consecutive months without
streaming and you're talking about ten
hours which is two hours a week a little
bit over so when you are breaching that
contract so evidently in that way and
you are actually in that period asked to
stream there were several occasions
where I brought up that you guys have to
stream and if you look at the total
difference between what he was deducted
as penalties because it's very simple
mathematics it is your hours amount of
months there's a fixed price in the
twitch Agreement you can time those
together and you will get an amount that
amount you get is significantly higher
than what he was deducted I also asked
him how and why Fryeburg prize money was
in any way connected to his inability to
stream because to my understanding that
was never written anywhere into the
player contracts that they signed in the
contract it is not defined if it's
salary prize money or something that
comes after in the the contract it is
defined and the contracts that we have
today are done by CMS which also does
the contracts from Bundesliga in Germany
would football so for us when we went
through the legal process with the legal
agency that developed these contracts
for us it is not specified how you are
doing it to the detail in the recipe it
is still adept that the company had to
to Freiburg so we decided to withhold
that and not pursue for further because
the amount that we could have when you
look at the further damages proportion
and reclaimed that was much higher than
Mount now after talking with Freiburg I
also spoke to exists who told me about
his own issues trying to leave n IP
specifically that when he was benched
fnatic came to him with an offer
but according to exist Hashem told him
that the only way he was going to be
allowed to leave n IP was that if he
forfeited the prize money the
organization owed him so I got benched
and time goes by and I got offers from
different teams in the end I chose to go
with the face
had a really good offer for me and I
wanted to play with their players so the
whole negotiation took a long time and
in the NHL seem like everything is done
but you have to give up your price
winnings that I still have with NIV I
believe it was I am Auckland does 17
which we want so it was kind of much
money hms is blaming other board members
it's not his doing and he would never
want to keep me hostage in my contract
and after speaking with exists my final
interview was with Drakon who discussed
his own issues trying to leave n IP in
2017 they banished me and they basically
said we can't let you go to traffic if
you don't leave your prize money which
was twelve point eight so like 12 K
dollars according to him the reason why
exist in Drakon were asked to give up
their prize money was because the offers
that came in from different teams were
ridiculously low instead of telling the
players that they had to sit on the
bench until ni P received a better offer
hisham reportedly tried to come up with
a creative solution to release the
players from their contracts so fnatic
had an interest in exists
we had the negotiations they came back
with an offer which was very low we
cannot release exists for this amount to
fnatic I was quite fair and open with it
so I was like you have you have the
opportunity to stay on the bench here
and get paid your full salary the
discussions continued a little bit I
went back on my end and thought okay is
there a situation where we can let him
go
so one fact exists and I said I've
thought about a deal that we can propose
but you have to take your decision
yourself and after a little bit talking
about how it would work practically he
said okay to that so we said okay we'll
do this then I'll speak to fnatic see if
we can get the last piece finalized you
start speaking with them of your
contract but I never pressured him and
told him this is how we're gonna do it
do you understand the bench of a Phil
sorry or this is like the creative way I
can get around it for us to be somewhat
content as well with the outcome of this
so we did that deal we finalized with
fnatic that the terms and then they
started winning
so they went over to win wasg
they want captivate sir and then they
exist agreement fell through because
obviously they didn't want to do the
changes and that's when phase reached
out so I said to exist we can do phase
if you want to on the same terms so
listen I talked to this dude for two and
a half hours and he answered every
single question that I had and we
discussed almost every single allegation
that's been floating out there for the
past month to me as a journalist I
thought it was super important that not
only the players get their perspective
told but hisham and n IP management have
their perspective told and so towards
the end of this two-hour interview I
basically told them hey the floor is
yours please if there's anything that
you want to discuss or tell us on the
record now's your chance and here's what
he told me it has been a rough couple of
three weeks for us and everyone in here
is taking this situations very seriously
we're taking it a lot too hard I want
the fans that that sit on the outside
and look into this to understand that we
are doing everything that we're doing in
order to resolve every single case that
is coming in in total now we have ten
cases that has come in there's only one
left to resolve which we hope we will be
resolving very soon and to sit there
today
it feels especially when we go through
the cases and we talk about what has
happened
it feels very unfair and unjust I hope
that we internally now take this and
make it better from here not just for
things to not happen in the future but
also to improve everything else we're
doing so that is the main main main
objective for me and I also hope that we
are able to close this chapter and not
to too long and get back to competing
and entertaining fans and making them
happy and seeing our players lift
trophies again thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
will find anywhere else hit up our
Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]